United Airlines Flight
20 609 from Los Angeles to Boston.
It was a smooth flight
for the first 5 hours on Sunday
So where's all the security with
Because I'm waiting for them
to point the gun at me
so I can show everybody that I w
when I take everybody back.
Flip to wherever my body they sh
and I will kill every man on thi
The agitated passenger is identi
as Francisco Severo
Torres of Massachusetts.
The video obtained by
CNN was recorded by a passenger.
It shows Torres having violent o
towards other passengers
and flight attendants.
I love you young guys
coming from New York.
4 minutes.
Nervous passengers sat down and
Nobody cares.
We're hurting us
because wherever it is, it's
gonna be a bloodbath.
Every 15 seconds
later, Torres
walks out of his seat, pulls
what appears to be a makeshift w
out of his jacket pocket
and said what
no airline passenger ever wants
from taking over this plane
right now.
Oh, I'm telling you right now.
Well, United
Airlines says
there were no reported injuries.
The Justice Department says Torr
rushed towards
one of the flight attendants
in a stabbing motion
with a broken metal spoon,
hitting the flight attendant
on the neck area three times.
Torres also told law enforcement
that he tried
to open the emergency door
to jump out of the plane.
Torres also claimed
he was defending himself
because he believed the flight c
was trying to kill him.
Video shows passengers
and crew members
tackling and restraining Torres,
a passenger, told CNN.
Torres remained
restrained for another 30 minute
before the plane landed safely.
At Boston Logan International Ai
where Torres was arrested
United Airlines says
Torres has been banned from futu
flights on the carrier.
He is detained right
now, pending a hearing
before a judge on Thursday.
So you have this.
But we're also learning
of a new runway incursion
that is
under investigation this morning
the sixth recorded this year.
What do you know Joyce?
Well, this we're just learning a
it happened on February 16th,
according to the NTSB,
but it's investigating this inci
Now, as
these planes were both on the ru
near the same time
American Airlines
flight cleared to land on the ru
Sarasota, Britain's
International Airport,
as an Air
Canada Rouge flight was taking o
We know the NTSB is investigatin
No doubt it will come up tomorro
during a Senate
hearing
with the acting administrator of
Another safety
incident on America's runways Do
All right, Pete Manchin, thank y
And joining us now is Lisa Olsen
who was the passenger on that Lo
to Boston flight.
She actually captured the video
that we have been showing you
this morning.
And Lisa, first off, oh, my good
And we are so glad that you are
because obviously
this could have gone terribly
and we're grateful that you
can join us this morning.
What was it even
like to be on this flight
The first
the first 5 hours of the flight
was uneventful, quiet, normal fl
I was on with my husband and my
And, you know, about 30 minutes
before we were landing,
I heard a commotion.
He was getting louder
He's about two rows
diagonally in back of me.
And he just started rambling abo
you know, his father's Dracula,
the Nazis, just a lot of ramblin
and he was just getting louder
and louder.
A couple of passengers
tried to talk to him to calm him
It was only making him more agit
Women tried to approach him
and say that,
you know, he was scaring the pas
He didn't care.
He was getting louder.
And then a very large black belt
guy started
walking from the back of the pla
up to him.
And when he saw that,
he kind of
jumped out of his seat
and got in the aisle and
started to, you know,
like fight him
or attempt to
kind of pretend to fight him.
I didn't see a weapon in his han
at that point, but he was
my husband was in the aisle seat
So he was standing right
next to my husband.
I didn't see the spoon shrink
until I saw the video after afte
And then he turned
and ran towards the front of the
The United Crew was amazing.
They blocked the first class ent
which led to the cockpit.
The flight attendants were there
Many men from the plane jumped u
followed him, tackled him to the
And there were probably about fo
to six of them
that sat on top of him to restra
The flight crew, you know, immed
had zip ties
to zip ties feet in his arms.
He was still screaming
and he somehow escaped from the
They put new ones on him.
And as the men were getting tire
from restraining him,
they kind of swapped out.
And, you know,
the ones that were tired
would come back to sit down.
And people were thinking
and very appreciative that, you
they jumped into action so quick
Yeah,
he actually escaped from the zip
ties at one point.
He did.
I think he was he was so out of
I don't know if they didn't
get him on tight enough.
I don't know exactly what happen
if he busted out of them
or if he just wiggled out of the
But he was still very combative
for the beginning part.
So it may have been that
people at that point,
once we knew that there were onl
you know,
one additional set of zip ties l
People were sending up their bel
to help restrain him.
That it's
remarkable to see how quickly
all of your fellow passengers re
The fact that you were able
to have the presence of mind
to record this
when you were sitting so close t
is remarkable.
I can't believe there's just
just full of zip ties left.
Did you notice anything beforeha
you know,
when he was boarding the plane
or in those several
that's a really long flight.
And you noticed
any weird behavior from this man
before then?
I did not.
And I questioned myself on that.
But he was in back of me,
so I didn't see him board
he was sitting in the exit
row in the middle,
but he was two rows in back of m
on the opposite side.
So he was kind of joggling in ba
I didn't
I didn't notice him until I hear
Yeah.
He he attacked a flight attendan
Do you know how
the flight attendant was doing y
what was it like
getting off the plane after you?
You safely landed
So when he stormed to the front
and he was on the ground,
he was,
you know, the last
it was probably 30 minutes.
They had him down there
you know, towards the end,
probably 5 minutes, maybe 10 min
He was quiet.
He was screaming a lot before th
And as soon as the plane landed
I think the flight attendant was
I don't think it was a
deep puncture wound,
but he was right in front of the
when they had him on the ground.
The police, the Massachusetts
State Police came on board,
cuffed him, took him off the pla
The EMT
came in and intended
to the flight attendant
in the morning,
they came back and questioned
some of the passengers.
Listen,
this is a pretty jarring experie
I mean, we've been talking so mu
about close calls
with flight takeoffs and turbule
and all of these things
that have been happening in the
You know,
this incident happening now as w
Does it make you hesitant to fly
or scared to fly at all?
Ironically, no.
My husband
actually jumped on
another flight yesterday
morning and left.
I had my 17 year old daughter wi
She was very upset during the wh
She was crying.
She thought that we were going t
But for whatever reason, the Uni
plus all the passengers
being able to act
so quickly just was very comfort
I had confidence, complete confi
that they had everything under
control and I didn't feel
you know,
unsafe or in danger
during that time period.
A lot came out after the fact.
I think that I assumed that
when he started yelling
because he was quiet
for the first 5 hours,
that I thought
maybe it was drugs or
something happened where it just
it just set him off.
I didn't realize that
he was kind of planning this
from the beginning.
He was in the bathroom from a
for a long time
before that with his backpack.
I heard that
once the police officers
were questioning
the people in back of him
because there was a woman back t
that noticed that
he did
take his backpack into the bathr
He was there for a long period o
which is odd.
And the officers grabbed his bac
And the other odd thing
that I
kind of noticed was
I was expecting it to be kind of
And it was a very neat black bac
It had hand sanitizer in the sid
It was
just the
whole situation was a little sur
The entire situation is for Lisa
We're grateful that you recorded
so we could actually see it
and that you and your fellow
passengers were so quick
to respond to this.
Thank you for coming on
and for for sharing that with us
We're so glad that everything's
Please tell your husband
and your daughter
that we're thinking about them a